dad yes Carl there's something I gotta
know I don't want to use fear my
feelings I can handle the truth okay son
you have my word what's on your mind
I grew up I be able to grow a beard like
that near a Lassiter Lassiter men have
been growing legendary face wigs for
generations
it's a king's beard born in your blood
effected through centuries but never
forget it's not the beard that makes the
king I know I know so clean
that's right time we're almost there
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hold it priests had a family Carlton do
you remember why you're here thanks son
[Music]
[Applause]
Road you to check it out what is that
that is a gift for you meet Morrissey
the rescue dog here to rescue you from
your own handsomeness that dogs she fix
he was he kept biting her daughter
affection dog is with the vet called and
he's called it a rabies shot either way
the chief Gus and I have come to a
little agreement she said I'm loosing my
alpha since been away to her car did you
calls to come down here and the whole
thing just felt like a win-win that dog
was eating my foot mercy excuse me
Carlton I didn't realize you had
visitors oh whoa whoa whoa sorry no pets
pets I'm sorry oh that's Morris he's a
therapy dog does he have a vest he does
though he prefers to call it a waistcoat
I think you'll find it all checks out
this is an older flu t-shirt with tape
over the flu mpy in sharpie you good one
point for you Dolores my name is Shawn
Spencer and this is my partner bill
pooping Tain's no shell want
sidebar all right Carlton what is
happening right now let it go
built-ins what kind of nickname is that
Transylvanian Dutch why no Shawn no more
embarrassing nicknames especially in
front of peers and professionals Justin
don't be the night your dad fell asleep
inside your mom we can't fist up like
bits we've been doing for 10 years we
have fans they have expectations they'll
be a huge backlash Shawn we are two
dumbasses we do not have fans from now
Warren I'd do the nickname no no no
absolutely not that's disgusting
counterproposal you have right of
refusal until we land on when you like
it's a bad date but okay for now I'm
terribly sorry Dolores what I meant to
say was my name is Shawn Spencer and
this is my full-fledged partner all the
pips in one accepted hello Jim so let's
take a little walk with me hmm
lassie is that what I think it is
you